okay we are going to talk about hook oh
look look look whoo-hoo you know it's
most important ever give a stock really
yes I think you won't be great I would
have killed to see him even crazier um
so uh yeah a lot of people see my review
of and they know I'm kind of positive to
it even though there's a lot of stuff to
make fun of it's just it's not a bad
movie it's just inconsistent I hate the
kids with the exception of Bosco of
course we're like I I think I you could
say it's like is the one loss point
everybody can agree on like even people
don't like oh hey look like rufio's
awesome i everybody fucking loves your
feel you man
you stupid to do it uh but uh yeah y'all
know the story Robin Williams is a
grownup Peter Pan goes goes back to
Neverland uh first of all great concept
I think it's a great cancer what if when
they first showed the trailer it just
had the words like you know what if
Peter Pan grew up I'm like that's
fascinating and I love the fact that
they don't ignore um they don't ignore
like the psychological like repression
and kind of the what he's put away and
tried to forget what he's trying to hold
on to how much he actually really wants
to grow up maybe to forget the child
like it's actually a fascinating study
that's right you're Peter Pan more uh oh
you're having a breakdown
yeah and it's one of those things where
it's like some stuff is it you know like
a little corny like a lawyer joke yeah
yeah um and like I said mostly kita
you've become a pirate yeah so that
stuff is like fucking hammer on the head
um but yeah it's not the only ER aspect
I think is really like just super like
that the whole last act go is a little
much for me glad the last third is where
I lose it too
yeah which it's like she with and
strangely enough I'm most with the movie
until he becomes Peter Pan yeah that's
the problem I have with the movie I
actually all over this film until he
becomes Peter Pan and the first the
first time he becomes Peter Pan I'm fine
with it him flying over it's like him
not remembering - yeah like such a great
it's such a great Robin Williams own
because you know he always sold that
sort of enthusiastic join him flying and
and you know him standing there drawing
the line in the sand and all the Lost
Boys coming over and then Dante Bosco
somehow seriously delivering the line
you have a pan oh my that you know well
that was kind of cheesy but I mean
that's all fine and it's like right then
right there at that moment after he says
you are the pan and he create you know
he crows right after that the movie just
kind of just slides away to me like I
almost like if it's on television I like
she just kind of start flipping the
channel awesome yeah like that's where
it you know it's a document we need a
big sword fight you know I like that you
know it killing off characters you know
and stuff like that but there's
something to it's like then it's kind of
like you know turns into Spielberg slaw
yeah it's like we're kids film actually
know what it goes from Spielberg to
Spielberg it we go from kind of a a nice
mix of adult and kid friendly style I
like a decent balance like you a G rated
film yeah to to to the Disney climax of
like every anime film not you a G rated
film that yet somehow totally just kills
a character and the best character in
the fucking movie
um so yeah it's uh I think so so the
Laster and I would say four and I don't
blame the actors but the child actors
are really annoying and and they're not
being very it's for me it's that girl
yeah she's pretty bad she was a kid I'm
not yeah we're really not awake person
as a grownup you know I don't know what
the hell she went on to but in this
movie it's just ah
to the stand my ears the Sun almost
works uh cuz you can really see anything
like that but I've said seen with her
Bosch GABA clocks it's like Jesus Christ
yeah um but yeah it's one of those
things where you still over
Jr pinion man your defense is stupid
happy for fear like birthday thank you
I can't I just ya know it doesn't become
like on who much it doesn't give each
other is like a Disney animated film
becomes like Disney animated film from
like the 40s yeah the way they talk
um but yeah well then again you could
argue maybe they're all from the
Victorian era the 40s the army maybe
it's just the sequel to the Disney one
which was made well that was for the 50s
was their 60s I got a certified but um
but yet no but there was one something
that really made this fascinating to me
um I'll be totally honest I was watching
with my girlfriend the time and we were
kind of hi and we were watching this
movie notif as she brought up something
that actually legitimately blew my mind
I was like holy SH I'd never thought
about that
the scene where um he decides to go back
he sees Wendy's daughter Moira it just
immediately gets a boner and kisses her
or whatever I just kind of out know I I
guess he just finally hit puberty or
whatever um but and then she decides to
raise him and the girlfriend just
properly good point she says oh my god
that's beautiful I'm like what just love
at first sight or saying no the fact
that Wendy and him they were like a
crush she definitely had a crush on him
and then she gets older and then like
she makes the choice to see him not
choose her because obviously she's older
now but like her daughter and she
chooses to like raise him as her child
and stuff I'm like holy shit I never
thought about how like it's yummy or
creepy both it can be both beautifully
creepy okay uh but as soon as I heard
not like oh my god like I never thought
about that cuz you so do not see
obviously Maggie Smith and Robin
Williams as an item but it's like yeah
man when you really look at like you
know the time-lapse and who grows up and
who doesn't and stuff uh it's really
like though the best the best part of
the moments for me are really just early
on the between the John Williams score
which is it's one of his best yeah and
it's so
it you'll hear it again and again and
every single film sound sense like I
swear to god it's all hook between the
score and the atmosphere in the
cinematography those early scenes you
know where he goes into the nursery for
the first time and you see the murals on
the wall
the scene where hook invades you know
and they've got the thing going on at
the hospital at the same time you know
the after scene where she's explaining
that he's Peter Pan there's such like
this weird dark sense of mystery to it
like it's really it's like Spielberg
filmed it like Raiders of the Lost Ark
when I talk about finding me orchid you
get that we should win like oh like what
God is watching like the whole first
part of that movie has that feeling and
parts of it carry over in Neverland
early on but again once he becomes Pam
that it just gets chucked out the window
and it just becomes kind of like a
completely different feel like a goofy
kids comedy oh and don't get we need the
fun I get it we need the fun a spaz
Peter Pan but no I agree I believe his
best work is also in the first part of
that aura you know the I love the scene
where he's recounting you know when he
wanted to leave Neverland he's like I
wanted to become a father and you know
like there's some great acting there and
like I'm sorry but the stuff in the
third part it's just Robin Williams's
shtick and like had Rommel Eames never
done that before I probably be like oh
wow all is but it's just it's marking
Mindy it's like every single thing we've
seen I'm like okay so we went from
really good Robin Williams performance
that was really interesting and doing
different things to and back to this day
you know and I'll make a little bit of
an argument too and I'm not blaming
Williams for that I get the feeling
that's what they wanted oh well I'll
make look at the argument to that when
we decides to be a kid again okay
imagine that Laster that Robin Williams
are there imagine he's not an adult
imagine you just were told like you know
whatever he's uh thirty years younger or
something like that you know and this is
Peter Pan
would you believe that's Peter Pan I
wouldn't I believe this is a guy going
around trying to really energetic and I
begin I'm a kid haha what's it first
it's a first scene with Tinker Bell's
like yeah then the wind a lady flicked
the program
I'm like shut up I think this is
terabyte there there's definitely this
wild child aspect you want to catch her
but he's way too much I got a goofy I'm
silly ha ha ha where there's definitely
like this sort of dark even kind of
blood hungry aspect of Peter Pan and
yeah I always felt that Peter Pan was
more like the awkward early teen years
like and Robin Williams plays it like
hoes a movie I am Jack er yeah Jack yeah
yeah I because I am Sam uh playing it
like Jack like and I'm like no Peter Pan
shouldn't be like a ten-year-old there
should be that kind of crazed young
teenage sort of angst of like you know a
wild child but he's still a leader
somehow and I never I never yeah oh he
got that from you know the performance
and the third part I'm just like well
he's acting like not even a 10 year old
like some of those scenes I'm like this
feels like a six-year-olds rant like
yeah right no an adult trying to pretend
to be a kid which on the one hand you
could argue well that's what he is he's
trying to go back and the plot the part
where he's like he doesn't remember even
that he has kids and stuff like that I
can kind of buy that cuz it's like such
a relapse I can buy that I know it is
okay here's the problem the first part
the film did such a good job of setting
up the mystery and everything that
there's a key scene where Maggie Smith
opens you know the book is that here to
tell you about who you really are Peter
dude she she opens the book and there's
this image of him like you know doing
the whole pose and everything and like
the music's all kind of creepy and dude
and like I'm like okay that's like
mystical and like you know there was
sort of an intimidating presence to that
picture that's like all of us is what
weirder than we have just like I don't
know why hook would have been scared of
this guy late just kind of seems like a
little nut no I think I think there's
yeah there's something to it there is a
dark edge that I'm not saying none of
the Peter Pan's ever get and other
versions I think actually a lot too um
but there's still something missing -
like - Peter himself where it's I never
quite get just how like kinda like you
said there's the authority but there's
all
so sort of a dark craziness to him -
this is kid that says I you know it's
like I don't want grow up I'm going to
run away and I know it's like Oh
Pinocchio song about run away this kid
actually fucking dead it yeah and so
he's got to be a little nuts but there's
also got beat authority like no I just
waited I'll you know I'll tell you oh
fuck I just realize he should have been
like fucking Rufio is with it that's
what I'm thinking of maybe not quite the
edge that Rufio Hannah but more closer
to Rufio than Jack you know from maybe
maybe you know a bit more playful than
Rufio but yeah bit more maybe it's it
yeah the duck them the best Peter Pan I
ever saw a version of it which is sadly
I don't think it's on DVD and it should
be it was so good they made a show for
Fox it was called Fox with Peter Pan
I've hired by calling some Eddie's every
time I saw that show I'm like this is
Peter point everything curry that's
Captain oh yeah I mean you got to know
Harry's Captain Hook genius and the all
the characters were just like pitch
perfect like and they're such a
continuous and that's the thing I I
think that's what's missing is that I
don't get competent out of Robin
Williams's pan I gotta get more I mean
he's kind of incompetent cuz he's
learning the ropes but I kind of got
somebody trying out you but it's like
somehow they chucked to the competence
away he's like oh he's just like some
kid whereas the Peter Pan and Peter Pan
the Pirates I got competence yeah like
he was nutsi but he was confident he was
cocky it's like you just followed him
cuz he had no fear I know if I should
mention this cuz it'll destroy your
image of Peter Pan forever but if you
want a great interpretation of Peter Pan
along the dark and I mean fucking darker
than rufio's watch once upon a time
because they had a season with Peter Pan
it's probably my favorite season just
because they took a console but what's
so dark with it like Peter Pan's like
holding Wendy hostage and like is
working the brothers against each other
that it's freaking amazing and I'm like
wow it's dark there's an explanation for
it at the end which I won't give away
but it's like I didn't need that but
definitely like that Pam in particular
again just seemed just a little unhinged
but also like somebody who could lead
and like somebody that you would follow
yeah I think there's this idea that
Peter Pan
you know says such this magical fantasy
and this wonderful idea a child that
will never grow up and can fly as in
this magic land and stuff and that's all
great but there's always been this dark
edge to him as well you as some versions
now put it this way can you imagine the
Disney the 1950s version of Peter Pan
going over you sick well looked up the
windy lady put the thermometer on wrong
no you can't that Peter Pan wouldn't
have done that yeah because they took
the character seriously and that's kind
of where I lose the film is that it
takes itself really seriously like it's
Spielberg that some of his like best
it's like taking it's like Raiders he's
taking a ridiculously stupid idea like
so dumb like really we're searching for
the Ark of the Covenant and as this guy
with a fedora you know and his weapon as
a whip it's like if you write it on
paper your lights the dumbest idea but
the way he directed it and the way the
writing work that everything it took
itself seriously enough that it really
worked in like the first two-thirds of
hook really kind of do that and then it
just that third part just your I went
from Raiders to Kingdom of the Crystal
Skull but what I like too is they
balanced out just enough I think with
Dustin Hoffman as hook and Hoskins as uh
as me emails out that he Hamid II they
were a comedic relief yeah the villain
is actually more than funny and I you
know and his those two are so great yeah
i he's a great hawk he really was i mean
trying to stop me speed don't try to
stymie us lease me it was the perfect
amount of over-the-top it I thought so
legitimately could British accent that
he did um and yeah I just really love
that version of hook I can't say it's my
absolute favorite as I probably would
say Tim Curry's my favorite one
but it's out there uh and he's Bob
Hoskins just a great Smee cuz he looks
likes me for one thing yeah Oh what
about Smee Smee Smee yeah I like that
they play up the ego too there's got to
be a red carpet for them and stuff like
that so they still have a comedic aspect
to it as well um but yeah because if
there's a lot of people I think for a
while that have like mixed feelings
mostly lean towards the negative of this
movie and now I think over
people come around like weather than
dystocia factor whatever really liking
this film I feel really I think I'm
sorry I what have I like words I'm
honored I went through a phase where
when I first saw and I'm like I was
alright like we went to a school field
trip and we all wanted to see alien 3
and it was a hook not in retrospect we
actually locked out because alien 3 was
a bit of a downer um but we didn't know
at the time we thought was gonna be as
good as alien so I think we all came out
and really that was all right like I
think we were all surprised it was
funnier than we thought it was gonna be
a cuz even though is pg-13 we kind of
thought it was gonna be a kid's film and
even though it ended it that way you
know so I kind of it was alright and
then somewhere in high school I went
through this phase I'm like as movie
sucks it's really cheesy and now like
when I look at it like from a filmmakers
perspective like with a real critical
eye I'm like no there's a lot of good
things in there it's just inconsistent
it's as very skittish out it's like two
separate movies going on one really
really good and the other just appointed
kids just a corny kids film yeah and for
like I saw for the most part they
bounced out okay until you get to the
very end I think we always had this big
discussion that Spielberg doesn't end
his films very well no um you know it's
like some he can't but I mean for that
it's always like he's just but tie this
ending he ever hand I think was still
Jurassic Park hmm just and we're gone
we're done yeah by chronic about the
t-rex comes it drops the fucking mic
helicopters John Williams music we're a
team I'm like yeah anything else I think
he realized it somebody's like you know
what fuck it we're just do you know I'm
out so say sing with the edge owns of
the third one it's like as soon as I say
so longer than you saw everything you
need to see it's just like you know and
I and you're just done it's the rocky
ending just and uh some users had a good
ending to he cannon did good but it's
not consistently well yeah so but uh but
yeah so uh I still really like the flick
I like um I really like that the guys
took the psychology of this drone uh
Peter Pan I think it's something that I
was watching the Cisco Depot review of
it and they were saying you know I
wonder why Spielberg just didn't do
Peter Pan why didn't he just tell the
story a Peter Pan
them and I just think this is still such
a good concept no Peter Pan you know
forgetting about his past and trying to
regain and trying to remember his
childhood and repression it's it's a
fascinating idea I'm not sure and I
don't mean this to insult Spielberg I'm
not sure what he would have added to
Peter Pan that we didn't already see
before like if you're gonna do something
like Peter Pan have a reason for it like
yeah and this seemed like a reason like
to sort l-like this kind of yes
interesting sort of and I like that
concept did he do it perfectly no but I
like the idea of doing something
different with it better than just like
oh well we should have just done Peter
Pan I'm like we've got a million
versions of Peter van there's already
had me Peter Pan the Pirates had already
been out by the time that film ran I'm
pretty sure it was like 90 maybe so yeah
I have so I've never seen you know like
I said the closest definitive pan I've
seen is the one that didn't even really
follow the book it made up its own
stories with the TV show the Fox is
Peter Pan the Pirates all the other ones
even the ones I like like I like the
Disney one and you know and uh the hook
is like a spin-off or whatever but I
felt like you know none of them ever
quite got the definitive story in a
perfect mix of like you know good pacing
and good fantasy and good dark and good
bright and good comedy good drama
uh nothing ever quite got it totally
100% like what I feel the book was
trying to do um and I'll go maybe it's
still out that I don't think this new
whatever this prequel this pink will uh
uh with you Jack my don't think that's
gonna be a B never know might be good
Oh Rose yeah but I I'd be like I said I
would like I wouldn't like to see a
definitive version that's like oh like
that was a like they tried it I want to
say I'm not sure we'd give it to
Spielberg no no no right I don't think
it's all right choice yet I don't know
who the right choice would be um but
it's like I think in some ways hook is
the reason why because he never could
mesh the kids film in the adult film
together there was like a disconnect
so I'm not sure he's the one like if you
want a definitive version I don't know
who I would pick but they tried one a
while ago uh I forget why I came out I
wants a mid-2000s and it wasn't it
wasn't awful it wasn't good uh it
definitely tried to do stuff closer to
the book but it was just a little too
jumbled and I did like Hugo maybe Martin
Scorsese could do it then you could have
two kids films on that actually I'd be
down for that I think be pretty cool to
see um but it's kind of like Huck Finn
as well so we all know the book but we
have yet to have like that definitive
movie like the closest we had are you
saying the Elijah Wood version isn't the
definitive engine they like Elijah what
was great in that Omani I not the
definitive proof Pete shouting go to the
glory fuck come on dude I actually do
not just like that film but it's it's
not Huck Finn it's there me Huck Finn is
like holy shit doesn't make uh oh my god
ponies Huck Finn yeah but but it's not
as bad as like as you would think
there's a Tommen Hawk remember that the
job to tailor tapas Oh God oh my god
yeah but the funny thing about the funny
thing about Huck Finn is I'm just like
Elijah Woods at a time like he looks
exact same AG Dustin oh yeah we just
watch over the garden wall this
interview I'm just like yeah just give
Huck a little bit of a mustache
it was the same that dudes gonna look 21
for them yeah life uh but we're getting
off track uh so yeah I still like just
like Dante Basco brother brought back so
variable drinking the unicorn business
of young um but yeah I still really
enjoy the movie there's some parts that
are too corny for me but I think the
good aspects are just too strong and to
me yeah the standouts are Robin Williams
obviously the the first two-thirds in
particular I'm not a fan much of the
last third Dustin Hoffman and Bob
Hoskins and then of course Dante Bosco
yeah I mean it hands down the best loss
was 30 when he filmed that uh
Dante Basco was 45 when he filmed that
yeah um uh and yeah I thought I liked
them but Maggie Smith is really good you
know yeah she is good I like that I like
the boy enough I think he did a passable
job um I thought he was believable hmm
that girl now it's the way some about
the very shouty you should yeah yeah
yeah it's like dot I'm the cute one and
then the the other Lost Boys were kind
of similar most of them just kind of
blend into one like kind of awkward
child perform if you want a fun opinion
as Brad's opinion of Oh Brad Joe no what
is Brad fo he hates it he's like I'm
totally on the side of the fucking
father in this no you know he is a
lawyer if you started to get this
goddamn orphanage off the ground and
everything shut the fuck off your teeth
my teacher he'll be like oh okay I've
ask him yourself
I'm kind of like just browning words and
stuff like that how some people are just
gonna like launch in debate yeah hey I
got us some interesting emails here
buddy yeah you wouldn't know anything
about fishes would you what the fuck
dude I thought that was between you and
no III don't know if you hate if I know
like he's not a fan of it and mostly
because my right I am I will say I will
say this I don't disagree with Brad's
assessment early on for me it's when the
kids throwing the baseball on the plane
I'm like fucking prick will you not get
the fuck off and I was a kid when I saw
them I was but um yeah we wouldn't be
able to get away with that I was 12
years old when I saw the movie and I'm
like dude even I wouldn't fucking do
that
like just that's just douchey this is
the past so I'm kind of with Brad on
that I'm like yeah and he's like trying
to get an orphanage off the ground
there's this big deal and like they're
freaking and say now here's the only
thing that always did bother me about
that scene is and then the one thing in
the kids defense is yeah they're being
insane but like wine and ramblings just
go to another room yeah that's a big
freakin house it's like where you cared
shut up Oh like or I could go to the
other roof so uh no it definitely still
like you have negative aspects of it but
I
the positive ones are just too good and
I I would also argue the one last look
at the art direction and set design
I know Cisco livre complain about they
always worked like a fad and I'm like
yeah but I kind of want them not you
know what it is close the whole
Neverland looks like a painting it's a
CGI painting room the tab meant to look
like a painting like something out of
what dreams may come and I'm like the
set pieces should kind of match that it
should have that storybook quality
feeling and I'm completely well I'm the
my thing now now we're praying for sets
in movies cuz we see so many now it's
like oh that shit's really there when
you get this tracking shot that shows
like the entire set it's like it's
ruined they're like the winner of Cisco
Niebuhr were alive today of now they
would be complaining it's like I'm a all
looks eg the sets because I'm with you
I'm just like I pray for real sets
everything now is just like fuckin guys
and frog suits in front of green screens
and I'm just like can we please just
build something I give Peter Jackson
that credit at least in Lord of the
Rings I thought there was more CGI
probably than necessary in Hobbit but at
least in Lord of the Rings I'm just like
a real sets like he built these things
and he built the bigotry models any but
you know you don't have to CGI the whole
thing so um yep that's about it and
we'll see you next time on a real Fox
take care